and then i was here in 77
when uh walter payton came in here the
date after he had rushed for 275 yards
getting minnesota and line them up right
here in the chair and they're going to
pitch it to proof
oh daddy tell me something how do we
know that's really painful
hello
and welcome to another episode of rt
essentials i'm jacqueline coley although
black filmmakers have been a part of
hollywood since the early days of moving
motion pictures they have often been
marginalized and stereotyped throughout
the years but things are improving and
new standards are being set in part
thanks to the films and filmmakers we'll
be talking about today and yes whoopi
spike and beyonce and even more people
with more than one name are on this list
and all of them are likely to bring a
smile to your face because this list is
our list of the best movies that
celebrate black joy
dream girls stop bringing us down and
get back there
why curtis you don't need me all you
care about is her bonnie
oh what
hopefully we didn't catch you
daydreaming as we kick off this list
with the 2006 musical drama dream girls
the academy awards darling was directed
by bill condon and stars jamie foxx
beyonce knowles eddie murphy and
jennifer hudson in her acting debut it
was adapted from 1981 broadway musical
of the same name which was inspired in
part by the famous motown record label
act the supremes the film looks at the
evolution of r b music in the 1960s and
70s through the eyes of a detroit girl
group called the dreamettes and later
just the dreams consisting of deanna
played by beyonce effie played by j hud
and l'oreal played by anika noni rose
after the girl group gets discovered by
jamie foxx's ambitious manager character
curtis taylor jr they find themselves as
backup singers for a national star
played by murphy curtis takes creative
control of the group and pushes them
into the spotlight which is only big
enough for just one of them to become a
star while the others are forced out all
in part due to the high cost of fame and
don't we all know how high that cost is
new wigs
the expensive kind
brand new costumes to appeal to a
younger crowd
and um
effie
then he's gonna sing lead
dean is doing what with the production
budget of around 80 million dollars this
was one of the most expensive films ever
to feature a predominantly black cast
and crew at the time and the result
eight oscar nominations in 2007 the most
that year and picking up two of those
for best sound mixing and of course best
supporting actress for jennifer hudson
in her acting debut y'all critics had
plenty of love for the certified fresh
dream girls as well with an overall
consensus praising the film's
electrifying performances and the
dazzling musical numbers while james
christopher from the times uk called it
a glossy gleaming cadillac of a film
with a vintage rhythm and blues engine
so guys let's go take it for a spin
drumline whatever you big ball-headed
boogie my first drum habit
no method man yeah fluff daddy
sam better than me
trying to hear you you ain't heard me
since i stepped on campus cause i know
what you about
about me
marching to the beat of its own drumline
is the next film on our list yep you
guessed it 2002 coming of age teen drama
drum line directed by charles stone iii
from projects like bernie max mr 3000
and makai pfeiffer's paid in full this
film was inspired by the college
experience of fame music producer dallas
austin who's produced the likes of nsync
janet jackson tlc and boys to men just
to name a few nick cannon in his first
film role stars as devin miles a
talented street drummer from harlem who
graduates high school and finds himself
enrolled in a historically black college
near atlanta one that takes enormous
pride in its marching band expecting to
be the top dog in the band's drum line
devin ends up butting heads with the
leader of the drum section played by
leonard roberts while also finding time
to woo an upperclassman dancer played by
zoe saldana
[Music]
mr miles
i guess you didn't like the required
piece as written
no i just thought i had a little
something something on him
impressively nick cannon did much of his
own drumming on screen i know it's
pretty wild but perhaps even more
impressive is the fact that nick and zoe
were nominated for best kiss at the 2003
mtv movie awards and while they didn't
win in this case it truly was an honor
just to be nominated because they lost
to possibly the most iconic kiss in
cinema toby maguire and kirsten upside
down in spider-man drumline was deemed a
success at the box office pulling in
almost 60 million dollars that resulted
in a 2014 tv movie sequel which
premiered on vh1 with nick cannon
returning but only in a supporting role
he passed the styx if you will to
newcomer alexander schiff who stars in
this version and with a 91 certified
fresh rating on the tomato meter critics
were lining up to complement drumline
with a consensus that it's essentially a
sports movie with drums the energetic
film somehow manages to make the
familiar seem fresh
love and basketball
i'll play you
what
one game one on one
for what
your heart
you out of your mind the next film was
an absolute slam dunk to be on this list
for a few reasons and i'm talking about
the 2000 sports drama love and
basketball spike lee was among the
producers for this film which was
written and directed by gina prince by
the wood in her directorial debut she
said her goal was to write a
semi-autobiographical film that felt
like a black hairy meat sally
in the film sana latham and omar epp
stars monica and quincy or q childhood
friends and next door neighbors growing
up in los angeles where they both aspire
to be professional ball players quincy's
father zeke played by dennis hasbert is
an nba all-star and quincy is a natural
phenom on the court while monica is not
the star of the team but is intensely
competitive over the years the two find
ways to challenge each other while also
eventually falling for one another but
of course their basketball dreams are on
separate paths making it harder for them
to stay together the film also performed
fairly decent at the box office and has
built a cult following throughout the
years perhaps it's the major league 2
reunion with omar epps and dennis
hasbert or the appearance of gabrielle
union who auditioned for the lead role
but was cast as quincy's high school
girlfriend or it could be the fact that
omar epps played a character named q
once before in the 1992 tupac movie
juice or maybe people just really really
love love and basketball and i am
absolutely one of them critics called
this certified fresh flick a winner with
a consensus that it's confident
directing and acting deliver an
insightful look at young athletes the
chicago readers lisa al specter further
praised lathan and epp saying they
reveal their character's motives with
nuances of expression that transcend the
dialogue
barbershop
and then
with with a straight faith got the nerve
to want to be somebody want somebody
respect you
but it take respect to get respect i'm
saying
whether you're looking for a line up a
fade twist out our locks go ahead and
grab a seat and go ahead and lift up
that chair because our next film is
2002's barbershop this dramedy is about
the day in the life of a barber shop on
the south side of chicago and it stars
ice cube as calvin who inherited the
struggling haircutting business from his
late father and sees it as nothing more
than a burden so without telling anyone
he sells the barbershop to a greedy loan
shark played by keith david who secretly
plans to turn it into a strip club but
as calvin starts to realize just how
important the barbershop is to the
community he looks for a way to get it
back cube is joined by an ensemble cast
that includes anthony anderson sean
patrick thomas eve troy garrity cedric
the entertainer and michael ealy in his
first major acting role and one of the
film's producers george tillman jr said
he was looking to achieve something
similar to the 1997 certified fresh film
soul food which he wrote and directed by
portraying african americans in a more
positive and three-dimensional light
than many other hollywood films had done
in the past
how come he gets to eat out front or the
rest of us cause eddie oh man you see
this
you see that right there what that mean
that mean i got c roy the film also
edged up the competition at the box
office grossing nearly 80 million
dollars on a 12 million dollar budget
and opened the door for a couple of
sequels with much of the poor cast
returning plus a barbershop series and a
spin-off called beauty shop with queen
latifah in the lead role critics took
just a bit off the side of their
assessment with this certified fresh
film with
indie wires wilson morales saying that
it put forth a dialogue with a high
sense of realness that folks could
relate to an overall consensus from
critics is that besides bringing up the
laughs barbershop displays a big heart
and demonstrates the value of community
black is king we have always
been wonderful
i see us reflected in the world's most
heavenly things
black
is king
all right everyone prepare to revel in
the beauty grace and artistry of
following beyonce knowles across the
globe in a celebration of black women
and that's because we're talking about
her 2020 musical film black is king
written directed and executive produced
by beyonce knowles which she calls a
passion project this is a visual
companion to the 2019 album the lion
king the gift which was curated and
produced by beyonce it tells the story
of a young african prince who is exiled
from his kingdom after his father's
death he undergoes a journey of
self-identity as he becomes a man using
the guidance of his ancestor played by
beyonce along with a childhood love and
his own subconscious trying to reclaim
his throne the journey for the prince
serves as an allegory for the african
diaspora's journey of discovery
reclaiming and celebrating their culture
and heritage which is accentuated by the
spoken word poetry that focuses on the
question of black identity history is
your future
[Music]
one day you will meet yourself back
where you started
but stronger
the super mega top secret project was
released on disney plus where it was
responsible for a reported three million
new subscribers for the platform and
with numbers like that to quote her
husband beyonce is more than just a
businesswoman she is a business
woman and beyonce is not the only family
member that got in on the mix you can
also catch her young daughter blue ivy
singing on the single brown skin girl
for which she actually won a grammy
blackest king received a total of six
grammy nominations including best
musical film and won a couple for best
music video and best r b performance
which made beyonce the most awarded
singer and female artist in grammy
history with 28. i mean did anybody
doubt it beyonce put all of her earnings
from disney back into the project to
ensure they had the best crew in
production for the film and the result
was a certified fresh hit with fans and
critics with a consensus that simply
states beyonce is king while kate young
from npr went a little further saying
that drawing on the themes of the lion
king inheritance self-identity and
determination knowles repurposes the
story as a clarion call to black people
black panther check these out
remote
access chemoyo beans updated to
interface directly with my sand table
and what are these the real question is
what are those
the next film on our list is definitely
super and not just because it's a
superhero it's 2018's black panther it
was way back in 1992 when wesley snipes
tried to get a black panther film made
and just couldn't make it happen he
instead went on to become blade opening
the door for chadwick boseman bozeman
stars as t'challa and black panther
alongside others like michael b jordan
lupita nyong'o martin freeman daniel
kaluya leticia wright winston duke
angela bassett and forrest whitaker
boseman first appeared as the character
in 2016's captain america civil war
before officially arriving on the scene
with this film which finds t'challa
crowned as king of wakanda following his
father's death but he is challenged by
killmonger played by michael b jordan
who wants to change the country's policy
and kick off a global revolution written
and directed by ryan coogler this was
the 18th film in the mcu and marked the
first marvel studios film with a black
director and a predominantly black cast
plus with over 1.3 billion dollars made
at the global box office this is the
highest grossing film ever made by a
black director so let's give it up for
ryan coogler you cannot talk
one more word and i will feed you to my
children
i'm kidding we are vegetarians black
panther also received seven oscar
nominations including the first best
picture nom for a superhero film and the
first oscar win for an ncu film after
taking home trophies for best costume
design best original score and best
production design the sequel to black
panther wakanda forever is due in
november of 2022 but sadly chadwick
boseman died in august of 2020 from
colon cancer and instead of recasting
the character for the sequel leticia
wright who plays his younger sister is
expected to have a more prominent role
there's also a tv series set in wakanda
that's in development at disney plus
because as they say wakanda forever fans
and critics loved this certified fresh
film with an overall consensus from
critics that black panther elevates
superhero cinema to thrilling new
heights while telling one of the mcu's
most absorbing stories and introducing
some of its most fully realized
characters
sister act 2 back in the habit i'd like
to introduce myself my name is sister
mary clarence and i am yo mama
no sir let's talk about your mama who's
so dumb she got hit by a parked car
thank you if you'd like to see lauren
hill singing on screen long before she
ever joined the fuji's or perhaps seeing
oscar winner whoopi goldberg sing and
dance in a habit alongside the likes of
jennifer love hewitt and fergie well
i've got the film for you it's sister
act 2 back in the habit this 1993
musical comedy was directed by actor
bill duke and is the sequel to 1992's
sister act with whoopi goldberg
reprising her role
this time around goldberg's dolores van
carter is back working as a las vegas
performer when she gets a surprise visit
from her nun friends asking for her to
return as sister mary clarence but this
time instead of turning a ragtag group
of nuns into an amazing choir she is
tasked with turning a ragtag group of
teens into an amazing choir in the hopes
of keeping their school from closing
along with goldberg most of the original
cast reprised their role in the sequel
as well including dame maggie smith
kathy najimney wendy mckenna and mary
wicks
so you come to class
you do nothing
and you pass oh no we don't exactly do
nothing
we have a good time too
and for the second year in a row
goldberg earned an ntv movie award
nomination for best comedic performance
and for the second year in a row she
lost to robin williams first for aladdin
and then this time around for mrs
doubtfire
but i can't really argue with their
choice
luckily she has another chance to take
home that elusive award because after
years of discussion sister act 3 is
finally happening on disney plus with
tyler perry serving as a producer
alongside goldberg who is among those
repraising their role i guess there
ain't no mountain high enough to stop
this trilogy the film had an outstanding
haul of nearly 125 million dollars at
the box office and has since become a
beloved classic with a rotten tomato
meter score of 19
consensus from critics is that sister
act is off key in this reprise fatally
shifting the spotlight from whoopi
goldberg to a less compelling ensemble
of pupils and trading its predecessors
sharp comedy for unconvincing sentiment
whatever but as we like to say on our
podcast rotten tomatoes is wrong rotten
tomatoes is wrong
dope if you're busy i can come back
tomorrow or later no um no they're
they're about to leave yeah we were
dipping
okay cool thanks
hi hi guys next up on this list of best
movies to celebrate black joy is the
2015 comedy dope written and directed by
rick famouema who has been busy
directing episodes of the mandalorian
lately this film is about high school
senior malcolm played by shamiq moore
who enjoys life with his friends as they
bond over 90s hip-hop culture and play
in a punk band together a chance
encounter lands malcolm and his crew at
a nightclub birthday party for a drug
dealer named dom played by rapper asap
rocky and as things turn violent the
kids flee but not before dom secretly
hides a drug stash in malcolm's backpack
inventure ensues from there as they try
to elude the dangerous people who are
after the drugs and maybe try to sell
them in the interim hey you asked me to
do something for you i'm like what i'm
down i don't give a [ __ ] because you're
my people all right you're my
and this is where i would insert that
word it's nothing personal you still
might but i gotta slap the [ __ ] out of
you based on principles it was a
breakout role for shamiq moore also a
talented singer and dancer who had only
played small parts before getting cast
as the lead and although with asap rocky
who auditioned after helping his
then-girlfriend chanel iman get her part
as lily the cast includes zoe kravitz
tony revolori former lakers player rick
fox blake anderson from comedy central's
workaholics and kirstie clemons in her
very first role forest whitaker who
serves as the film's narrator also
produced the film alongside sean combs
and pharrell williams the certified
fresh film premiered at the sundance
film festival in 2015
to rave reviews the consensus from
critics was that dope features a
star-making performance for shamiq more
and a refreshingly original point of
view from writer director rick famouema
dope is smart insightful entertainment
queen of catway
checkmate she won she won
hey joseph you are not serious a girl
has given you treatment what lupita
nyong'o makes another appearance on our
list because we're talking about the
2016
family drama queen of catway the film
stars david owellio alongside niyongo
with newcomer medina nawenga who plays
10 year old fiona a girl who struggles
alongside the rest of her family in the
slums of uganda but her world is forever
changed after she meets a young
missionary named robert pedente played
by oelio who teaches children how to
play chess her fascination with the game
soon evolves into her becoming a top
player under robert's guidance her
success opens the door to a bright
future and an amazing chance to escape
from a life of poverty while becoming
one of the world's best chess players i
fear
certain things will never change
you are the youngest ever player to take
uganda to the chesswood impact
things are changing
the biographical drama was directed by
mironair who also decided to turn this
into a feature film after making a
documentary about the life of robert
kiente which in turn was adapted from an
espn magazine article and the book by
tom carruthers the result was a dual
production from walt disney pictures and
espn films queen of katwe was produced
in uganda and south africa and most of
the songs from the film are popular
nigerian songs heard all over the
continent alicia keys also wrote and
recorded the song back to life for the
film thank you miss keys with a
certified fresh 94 on the tomato meter
critics clearly loved the film
stephanie abraham from [ __ ] media said
as audiences and actors demand more
complex roles for people of color let's
hope we see more ground-breaking
projects like this one and the overall
consensus is that queen of cutway is a
feel-good movie of uncommon smarts and
passion and outstanding performances by
lupita nyong'o and david owellio help to
elevate this film past its cliches girls
trip look at me
okay come on now you heard what ryan
said just just be cool i'm gonna be cool
i'm gonna be cool i just want to say hi
that's all wait i'ma just say hello no
no no don't you say hello as we are
coming to the close of our list let's
leave on a high note and take a trip
down to new orleans because we're
talking about 2017's
girls trip directed by malcolm d lee
from movies like undercover brother and
scary movie five this film is about four
lifelong friends played by regina hall
queen latifah jaden pinkett smith and
tiffany haddish after growing distant
over the years the four traveled to new
orleans together for the annual essence
festival looking to relive their
sisterhood and tap into their rarely
used wild sides their adventure which
includes cheating husbands plenty of
gossip late night drinkings and a little
something called grapefruiting which
we're not going to talk about here but
you can look up later co-writer kenya
barris known for creating the series
blackish and its spin-offs teamed up
with tracy oliver and erica rivenoja who
together based the script on their own
experiences with their female friends
and the result was a hit making over 140
million dollars at the box office
becoming the first film that was
produced written directed by and
starring african americans to cross the
hundred million dollar mark she was
tripping yeah now she's happy freak nick
lisa is back
up energy is going to waste
along with the film's all-star cast
which includes queen latifah jada
pinkett smith
reuniting more than 20 years after
starring together in 1996 set it off the
film also features a handful of
celebrity cameos from stars like sean
combs neo mariah and new edition i love
a great musical cameo but we have to
take just one moment to remind y'all do
not look up grapefruiting while you're
at work both fans and critics were
definitely on board with this girl's
trip with indy wire's jenna morata
writing that the bond between the four
women and the occasional lack thereof
demands repeat viewing and a critic's
consensus that called this a rare
r-rated comedy that pushes boundaries to
truly comedic effect and anchors its
laughs and compelling characters brought
to life by a brilliantly assembled cast
and oh what a trip this list was i want
to thank you all for joining us as we
discussed our list of the best movies
that celebrate black joy now go out and
find some of these on your own so you
can feel the joy at home thank you all
for watching rt essentials i'm
jacqueline and we'll see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]